con esta medida que viene para la ya
debilitada figura de juan guaidó a quien
iván duque reconocía como el presidente
de venezuela
primero buenas noches a todos pues ésta
no existía en este momento cuenta y do
why do perdió aliados a nivel
internacional y sencillamente lo que se
demuestra en este contexto es que la
estrategia que implementó unos sectores
de la tela de la oposición venezolana no
rindió sus frutos y finalmente en este
momento pues es un momento en el que
necesitamos en el caso colombiano
restablecer relaciones
diplomáticas con venezuela para
solucionar un montón de temas que están
dentro de la agenda ahora cuáles son
estos temas más urgentes que deben
abordarse en el restablecimiento de las
relaciones entre ambos países
hay varios si por ejemplo el presidente
gustavo petro ha puesto que uno de sus
temas es el tema de monómeros en la
medida en que una de las estrategias que
tiene gustado petro es que es necesario
mejorar la seguridad alimentaria de
colombia y para ello requiere de
ciertos productos que produce la
compañía de monómeros y de esa manera se
reducirían los precios de los alimentos
en colombia el otro elemento que está
detrás de eso es comercio se necesita
hay ciertos sectores entre las
poblaciones de la frontera colombiana
que requieren reestablecer relaciones
comerciales con venezuela la medida en
que sus principales socios comerciales
se encontraban al otro lado de la
frontera y
lógicamente hay que establecer un
diálogo alrededor de la migración
venezolana hacia colombia y por último
sería el tema de seguridad de la
frontera ahora venezuela ya fue un país
garante en el proceso de paz que negoció
el estado colombiano con la
desmovilizada guerrilla de las farc como
puede el gobierno de maduro elaborar
ahora con la llamada pass total que
propone petro
puesto quería mirar un poco de eso sobre
cuál podría ser el rol del gobierno
venezolano en 2d en las concesiones de
paz con lln no quería esperar porque en
la medida de
generalmente la participación de otros
gobiernos en las mesas de negociaciones
depende de si las diferentes partes
estén con buenos ojos la participación
de los diferentes de un país u otro
entonces yo creo que tocaría esperar un
poco más para mirar cómo se desarrollan
estos ven concesiones entre la guerrilla
y el gobierno colombiano para definir
cuáles son o cuál es el marco en el cual
se va a llevar a cabo esa negociación
señor moreno concretamente con el tema
de la migración cómo afecta o cómo
beneficia el restablecimiento de las
relaciones entre colombia y venezuela a
los cientos de miles de venezolanos que
han cruzado hacia territorio colombiano
elvira una de las cosas es que por mucho
tiempo desde que se rompieron las
relaciones diplomáticas entre colombia y
venezuela
las oficinas consulares de venezuela se
cerraron entonces eso generaba un limbo
para los ciudadanos venezolanos que se
encontraban en colombia porque no podría
no podían expedir documentos que eran
necesarios en muchas muchas veces para
expedir cierto tipo de documentos en
colombia no podían expedir por ejemplo
pasaportes en ese sentido si se les
vencía el pasaporte o no tenían
pasaporte o por ejemplo en algún momento
se presentó este inconveniente de los
niños que nacían en colombia pero como
no no se podía considerar en su momento
a estos niños como colombianos pero
tampoco podrían expedir los documentos
para para
para adquirir la ciudadanía venezolana
pues eran
niños a muy corta edad que que no tenían
nación
y pues yo creo que en este sentido pues
que se reabra el consulado venezolano en
colombia es un es un gran paso para
comenzar a mejorar la atención de la
población migrante en colombia